new year new you all that sort of thing
cutting out all the bad stuff focusing
on the healthy stuff does it all work
well let's talk to fitness expert Joe
wicks who is here really good to see you
good morning but every year every new
year people sort of start on these so
whether you call it a fad diet or what I
mean how would you describe it well now
is the time of year everyone's their
most motivated to make changes in a life
whether that's with Fitness with
nutrition but I do think the biggest
mistake people make is doing something
too restrictive and just I've just done
a bit of research and and 2/3 of Brits
now believe this there's no there's no
one-size-fits-all approach for dieting
so rather than go on a really
restrictive diet and cut everything out
that you love it's about being more
flexible and just focus and I believe
when there's home cooking and a home
workout to really sustain your health
and fitness throughout the year how does
that work them because how do you know
if you're cooking at home or cooking
from scratch whatever it might be how do
you know it's it's healthy
well there's look I've got cookbooks
there's obviously Instagram as those are
websites there's so much content there's
so much people some of people out there
spreading really positive stuff around
nutrition so it's kind of just keeping
it simple as well if you remove
processed foods junk foods takeaways and
you just focus on going back to that
whole ingredients like you just cook you
know your mum and dad you to cook when
you're younger it's keeping it simple
and that for me is the key to success
and staying healthy all year round it's
part of the problem when it comes to
dieting at any sort any time of year the
people want a quick fix and I know what
that feels like the idea of saying but
you're gonna be a few pounds lighter in
six months is really hard to cope with
you want to be a stone lighter in a
fortnight what a lot of people focus I
think on just the physical aspects you
know look in a certain way losing weight
but that isn't it's not a big enough
motivator I think people need to focus
on the mental health and the energy it
gives you I've just done a workout this
morning I really broke a night's sleep
I've got a new baby but I've done a
little 50-minute work at my moods lifted
my energies lifted and when you when you
do it regularly when you when you
realize how good it makes you feel then
the physical transformation will come it
just takes time but your patience is a
very important thing when it come on
you've served 15 the only 15 minutes
which is you know it's not it's not a
lot but it's better than nothing so I've
got a YouTube channel where I do a lot
of workouts and stuff and I I just
believe that daily exercise just even if
it's 15-20 minutes just has a massive
impact and you obviously have to combine
that with nutrition and then if you do
the two you can live a healthy life it's
the
even doing something that that works see
that's manageable but actually that you
can sustain cuz I mean this sort of diet
I guess has to be never-ending in that
so you need to you know regime that you
can stick to good it's about the life so
I wasn't yeah and I was speaking some of
her down Instagram they said that
they've been spending 140 quid a month
on their gym membership for the past
eight months they've been twice and so
it's about kind of you know if it's too
I don't you know difficult for you to
get to the gym and have a personal trend
all these things that you think you need
you can really get fit and healthy just
from home and I I've obviously got my
youtube workouts I do all my recipes
I've got my gusto recipe to get
delivered each week and it really makes
things easy it's about keeping things
simple and I believe that if you can
make your home your gym that's the way
you're gonna get fit this year
what about vegan you arey cuz a lot of
people will be doing vegan you re it's a
danger in that and not against plenty of
vegans who live you know very good very
healthy lifestyles but if you're just
doing it for a month you need to be very
you need to really look into how to
alter your diet to maintain all the
right nutrients don't you yeah I think
you can be you know you can be very you
can do it very well you can do it very
helpfully you just got to do a bit of
research make sure getting all the
protein sources and having a variety of
you know food and nutrients but again if
it's that you want to try I just think
it's quite extreme to go from eating
loads of meat and chicken and fish to
going straight into a hardcore vegan
maybe then I try a mum producing things
trying some vegetarian food and and then
working up to that I think it's more
realistic to do it I think it'd be more
sustainable long into the future but
again it's if you feel good eating a
vegan die and it gives you energy and
you feel amazing then go for it if you
find it doesn't work for you don't feel
like you've got to do a certain thing
you know be more flexible in your
approach to dieting and eating yeah all
of this it sounds like it's more for you
it's alright though you look fantastic
but there's more about mental health and
then said then losing weight or whatever
I used to talk a lot about like my 90
day plan is like an online fitness plan
I use to talk about fat loss
getting ready for summer feeling good
looking good but now I actually talk
it's more about the mental health
aspects because people you know we're
struggling with anxiety and depression
and low self-esteem so exercise is the
most important and most powerful tool
that we can all use our disposal and
that's why I'm really on a mission I'm
now at working with kids in getting kids
exercising because it needs to start as
young as you can to incorporate into
your your mind and your life to really
enjoy
not all but Joe really good I feel I
feel alive I'm gonna do a workout today
I might have to do I'm gonna cook a
recipe I will cook a recipe in cookie
smell half way though if nothing else
good to see you thank you very much
indeed